dala Hi Sam it's Dalia Dalia okay Your
Voice Sounds Familiar were you on my
Skype the other day no no no no no it's
the first time I'm coming to speak to
you because you have that name of some
sister named but go ahead okay Sam so um
basically a few months ago I just got
really into um I just got really
passionate I'm a Christian right um I
just got really passionate because of my
job like to talk to Muslims and stuff
like that you know and I really just
wanted Sam you know you're so funny you
know I swear and after I would I don't
know I just got that passion if that
makes sense and I started studying I
would always come on your streams you
know go like to Christian Prince and
take notes and try to put everything
together you know like not everything
but you know what I mean like the
information that would get you know and
today I was actually talking to uh
muhammadan how you call him and
with Abdul and um yeah basically I was
really destroying him like literally
Islam lives through lies that's say like
interpretations and all of that right so
um he was just trying oh no that's not
what he means because I was just talking
how Muhammad basically was uh possessed
by like he was Bewitched I think that's
like our translation you know in English
he was Bewitched he was made to forget
things but after shatan does that right
that's B that was basically my argument
and I was showing him the hadiths the
Quran etc etc and he was like oh no
that's not what it
means but after he came with the
question and this is one thing that I
just struggled to like put my mind
around he's like okay I have the
information about the Bible about where
like the accuracy of the Bible like some
please yeah BAS
I'm waiting for you to finish your
sermon it's powerful it's moving me in
my spirit but go ahead thank you Sam uh
it was a good conversation right but um
it was just yeah he was just trying okay
if I believe you believe in your Bible
right you you have so many bibles and
this and that um and look why can I not
believe in my Quran right that was like
his question you know and he was like
what do you the Bible yes go on sorry
you didn't know how to answer that
honestly I I didn't I I did not have one
proper answer I have knowledge but I
don't have a proper answer so let me
repeat your question by the way are you
from you you sound like you have South
Africans accent are you from no I'm a
proper white girl you know from South
Europe and I live in I live in east
Europe sorry and I live in the UK I
thought you're from Africa all right
very simple if he told you if you can
believe in your Bible why can't I
believe in the Quran because
your Quran claims that the god of the
Quran is the god of the Bible and the
god of the prophets mention the Bible
and the god revealed in Jesus so if that
is true then the Quran has to agree with
the Bible but we see the Quran
contradicts the Bible so it has to be a
lie from hell so why do you want to be
believe a lie from hell and go to
hell period that's
it because it's true because the Quran
says that whever comes to them it has to
be first approved by the Inu and the
Torah yes it says Muhammad one of the
arguments Muhammad gave and you know you
I have articles on it sessions on it is
that his Quran confirms Bears witness to
the truth accuracy preservation of the
scriptures of the Jews and Christians
that's
inak IM I mean if you've been following
me I've done sessions with articles and
verses so if the Quran says this
Revelation is sent down by the same God
who sent the re the scriptures to the
Jews and Christians and this Quran
agrees and confirms that those
scriptures are true and they're
preserved they God's words and Jews and
Christians are to judge by them and yet
the Quran contradicts those scriptures
and that means the Quran is a lie and
Muhammad is a false prophet because the
Bible condemns his message so why would
you want to follow him when he
contradicts the very scriptures that he
says are the truth from God and
supposedly his Quran
confirms okay that really makes sense
right really makes sense
I feel like it's so honestly it's so
stupid because it's
like I don't know like I don't
understand how Islam makes sense in
their head I don't understand you know I
don't understand I'll give you two
answers you ready yeah number one it's
because it's cultural they're raised in
Muslim homes and Muslim families and
Islam is part of their DNA so they don't
know anything else and they don't know
any better or number two those who
become Muslim is because they didn't
know the Bible didn't know
and they were given a sanitized version
of Islam that made Islam look good J
know is very true because as I told you
basically I go into a relationship with
a Muslim right and wait hold on hold oh
there
Nelly yeah you're doing what with a
Muslim yeah I go into relationship with
him like are year
ago I didn't know like anything are you
still with him no no did you leave him
yeah basically just yeah don't lie to me
because God's going to no no no no no no
no we're not together and uh how long
has it been since
when since I left him no since you left
him yeah since we broke up um like a
month sister I'm gonna have to say this
in love okay in love because you you
brought it up you have no right to talk
about Jesus when you're with the man and
you're having sex with him I didn't have
praise God we were we were not like we
were not thank the Lord you kept
yourself pure yeah but you you said it
you put yourself on the spot I wouldn't
do this it was Private we talk private
but mention yeah though you didn't have
said glory to God you kept your Purity
yes was there kissing and touching yeah
shame on you sister I say this in love
shame on
you you have no right to be talking
about Jesus to a Muslim man because your
motive is not pure you're talking about
Jesus because you want him to become
Christian so you can be justified in
marrying him okay your motive is evil
because your motive is not for his
salvation it's for you to marry
him you understand how long were you
with
him eight months seven months okay what
business did you have even going out
with a Muslim don't you know your faith
enough that you're not supposed to be
with a non-Christian honestly I was not
that I was not strong I was really weak
did you know what I'm saying you knew
that as a Christian you're not supposed
to be with a
non-Christian yeah okay let me ask you a
question if you had a daughter would you
be happy if your daughter ended up being
with a Muslim and marrying a Muslim man
no why because after all the research
I've done and everything that I've done
and all the knowledge I have is just
stupid in my head would it hurt your
heart yeah I'm more interested in you
getting right with with God asking God
to have mercy on you and have mercy on
me and purify us and seal us that we
walk worthy of Jesus look I'm a man I
struggle but I try to ask God to help me
by the part of the Holy Spirit never to
succumb and be with a woman unless I'm
married to her and she's got to be a
Godly woman and if he doesn't want me to
get married his will be done may he give
me the power may we never shame Jesus
but sister I'm G to give you advice you
have no business to be witnessing to
Muslim men you have no business to be
interacting with Muslim men if you're
going to interact is going to be with
women women and women not women and men
and right now you need to get right with
God and ask God to heal you because in
your heart don't deceive me you have
emotions to him you're attached to him
which is why you're here talking to me
because in your mind even though you've
walked away You're hoping somehow he
becomes a Christian so you can marry him
correct yeah you're in
sin and you know what you just did let's
say you move on you now Dishonored that
Christian man
who may be interested in you and wants
to Mar because you're a Christian but
you went ahead and let a Muslim Steal
Your Heart that's
shameful that is wicked because let me
tell you something about God God loves
his sons just as much as he loves his
daughters and no good father wants a bad
woman for his son how do you want God to
give you to one of his sons when you let
a Muslim steal your heart and you still
have love for him cheating on your
husband Jesus and being unfaithful to
that God of man of God because if a man
of God finds out your heart is attached
to a Muslim he'll be
disgusted what are you
doing you better repent go back to your
church submit to your church and tell
them what youru is and never contact
that man again never if you love Jesus
okay yeah so thank you for that s thank
you keep I'm not saying it to be mean
I'm telling you I have to answer to
Jesus when I stand before the Lord he's
going to hold me accountable for my own
sins may have mercy and for what I say
and I'm not going to tickle your ear
you've let a man Steal Your Heart A man
who does not believe in your Jesus does
not believe in your God or your Bible
whose religion teaches him to mock your
faith and to and snare and and murder
your brothers and sisters which they've
been doing for 1400 years so give your
heart to that man when you are betroth
to
Jesus does Jesus deserve better than
what you're giving
him yeah he does then when are you gonna
stop hurting his
heart are we gonna stop yeah thank you
Sam thank please next time I want to
hear from you is when he say I have no
more feelings for him I'm free and I'm
In Love With Jesus well you still love
with this man because you're trying to
win him you're asking me questions
because who asked you that question he
did right no no it was someone else I
was talking to another Muslim not him
not him what is it another Muslim what
just another guy just another guy
another guy he's just an he's was an
older man he's just an older man like
you think an older Muslim man cares
you're younger an older man can marry
young women especially Christian what's
wrong with you I didn't know this no I
didn't look at it like that what's wrong
with you for the love of our Lord Jesus
who loves you stop talking to Muslim men
stop all right yeah all right get back
to me when you tell me
Sam Sam I no longer talk to Muslim men I
don't even get near them so I don't open
my heart to Temptation because I love
Jesus more and I have no feelings for
that man because you're still in love
with that man aren't
you yeah you need to repent and ask God
to heal you you have given your heart to
someone else you've cheated on your
spiritual H
husband you know who your spiritual
husband is Jesus and you cheated on
him you committed spiritual adultery
against your Lord that's 2 Corinthians
11 versus 104 you need to repent all
right yeah now go repent come back to me
when you have good news I have no
feelings for him I'm In Love With Jesus
I'm forgiven then you talk to me okay
okay thank you so much
okay sister take
care all
right you don't know how common this
story
is you don't know how common this story
is of people going after non-christians
especially Muslims it's more common than
you think